the recent attack on titan episodes have
been slowly unraveling everyone's
motives on paradise island
none of which are very simple or well
all that morally great
actually from pixis and the higher-ups
to edin and zeke
and the elena there's just so many
moving pieces at the moment
and i'm here to hopefully clear that air
a little bit and explain the goal of
zeke and mainly the jaegerists here the
group that is very rapidly taking the
center of attention in the anime
and you might wonder why not aaron and
the yeagerists why
zeke and the yagarists aren't they
following aaron's will
well yes but aaron's motives are always
very cloudy and they will continue to be
so
and the jaegerists are really just
people who are following aaron himself
and believe that he can save the aliens
not necessarily carrying out his direct
will
but anyway we'll get into that later but
i'm here to mainly clarify what the big
bad plan is
involving the wine the bombs everything
we've seen so far
and what will probably happen next in
upcoming episodes
and considering my girl peak is in the
walls do you ever look at someone and
wonder
what is going on inside their head
buenos dias
[Music]
a lot is going to happen soon let's
check it out
i think first and foremost we should
start with yelena who
while not necessarily the mastermind of
everything is
only second to zeke and aaron and has
had a hand in
everything currently happening on
paradise island
a bit before the attack on marley which
was what maybe 10 months ago
in the anime's time elena met with aaron
in secret to apparently make him act
because the military was too slow and
cautious
now volunteers can't directly meet with
aaron because the military is well
cautious of them and gets her military
detail changed to flock the big time
aaron fanboy who lets her meet him
and earlier i said elena apparently
incited aaron to act on zeke's plan and
attack marley
and i use the word apparently because we
can never really know when
elena is lying or not but considering
aaron did end up attacking marley soon
after
it can't really be far from the truth so
anyone who's still on team aaron i mean
it wasn't really his idea to attack
marley in the first place he can put all
that on yelena and zeke
and on top of all this using the survey
ships for marley as transport
elena has been shipping wine containing
zeke's spinal fluid to paradise island
though it was previously thought that it
paralyzed any ld in the moment they
drank it we are now seeing that this was
a lie as well since no one could attest
to this
except zeke himself the wine has not
only been given to the higher-ups of the
military but the survey regiment that's
currently guarding zeke in ragako forest
as well
oh and and falco too sorry buddy
you kinda had it coming
and what this means is that essentially
everyone who drank the wine is now
held hostage by zeke and the jagerists
and can be turned into a mindless titan
at a moment's notice
along with the reveal that hundreds of
jaegerists are within the ranks of the
military
all of our main characters like pixis
and hanji can't really act without
risking everything nicolo mentions how
zeke conquered an entire city in a night
through this method alone
but also on top of that wine there's
also the threat of the bombings we saw
used a couple episodes ago the paranoia
the fear that anyone around you could be
an enemy
the military is now stuck between a rock
and a hard place if you can even call it
that
they can do almost nothing but comply
while pixies of course still has his
plan
of feeding air into someone because he
can't be trusted with his titans
the odds of him getting to do this plan
doesn't look so good
the jaegerists have also been slowly but
surely gaining the public's trust as
well
starting first from flock leaking the
information that aaron was imprisoned
after his supposedly heroic actions in
marley
however you want to take that and now
the bombing
aaron is gaining more and more support
through the rapidly growing
mistrust of the military something that
the people of paradise island
are very familiar with considering the
whole corruption business and uprising
in season three
it's essentially setting up the
yeagerists and aaron himself
as the leaders of a new regime on
paradise island which
if they activate the rumbling will be
the only part of humanity
left alive so kings of the world i guess
i think what's been so blurry and kind
of confusing about elena is that you
never really know when she's telling the
truth or lying
and only now are we starting to see her
true colors
you guys remember in my waifu video
where i was like elena
no bruh elena all my homies hate elena
get gaby in there too this is what i
meant all of you guys know now
the weird ass chick bro also this dude
flocked this face right here
the jaegerists are scheming
and now we see that flock and other
jaegerists are trying to get zeke's
location from
hanji so it's very clear that their main
intention is still to bring
zeke and aaron together to activate the
rumbling
and you might think wait isn't levi
there isn't he gonna protect zeke
well there is a very foreboding scene in
the trailer for this season that just
might show you how it's going to go with
zeke and levi
levi has way more to worry about than
just flock and the others coming to him
but also who's already there in ragako
forest and what danger they pose
and so even though we know the jageris
plan at this point honestly i feel like
both
zeke and aaron's purposes are definitely
up in the air still
zeke has spent his entire life as a
traitor to marley his reputation is
built on having secret motives and i
really doubt he would have told elena
his true intentions
after all elena at the end of the day is
just a jagerstan
she holds no real power zeke and aaron
are the only pieces that are needed once
everything is said and done
to activate the founding titan and the
rumbling isn't the only option the
founding titan has many powers aside
from this
brainwashing genetic changes and more
so i don't think it'll follow such a
linear story
and aaron i mean i mean that guy's an
enigma but again there's no way aaron is
just following zeke's plan
exactly how he wants it you know just
because the elena supposedly convinced
him to
nah there's no way he's got his own
reason for doing all this which will
certainly be seen more as season 4 part
1 wraps up
i explained my take on aaron's plan a
while back in a theory video but
honestly at this point it's
kind of outdated and who knows theories
aren't always right anyway
so what should we expect from the last
four episodes of season four
part two well first the complete
takeover of the yeagerists
granted they've already kind of done
that in the last episode but once word
gets around
about the wine or zeke activates his
power and every military higher up gets
a pretty rude awakening
there will be no higher power to fight
the jageris regime
secondly aaron and zeke meeting along
with the fact that flock
is using hanji to find zeke's location
in the forest
and that the men in the forest have
probably been fed chock full of wine as
well
there's not much stopping these two from
meaning except levi
and then of course there's my girl peak
yeah
baby the marlins are going to strike
soon and if peak's there then there's
probably other shifters within the walls
so we might see a whole big war start on
the island in these upcoming episodes
it'll certainly be a huge finish to this
part of the season
a three-way fight between the survey
corps the jaegers and the marlians
on top of that throw in a probably
conflict of ideas between aaron and zeke
as they both attempt to use the founding
titan's power for what they want
as always this has been the anime
culture corner i hope you enjoyed the
video don't forget to like and subscribe
for future in-depth show
manga and character analyses